good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller
mas CP we're going to be looking at
today is SCP 439 object class Euclid
special containment procedures specimen
is to be kept at armed research site 45
hazardous life-forms wing in a sealed
locked 38 litre 10 gallon type G
containment unit with connected oxygen
supply specimen is to be fed through
feeding tube 16 a with approved
nutritive substance XF handling is
available to level 2 personnel or higher
description SCP 439 is an insect of
unknown origin somewhat resembling a
grayish semi-translucent for the
faculity coal area common earwig
approximately 2.5 centimeters in length
originally located or obtained in
mainland China in the province no other
specimen has been found as of yet SCP
439 is relatively harmless when it
counted on safe terms aside from the
ability to deliver a firm painful pinch
with its abdominal forceps the true
hazard this creature poses lies in its
habitat construction and reproduction
which is initiated when the specimen
enters the mouth of a sleeping human
this will only occur with humans other
life-forms have been presented to SCP
439 and have been uniformly rejected
upon location of a suitable host the
specimen will hide itself in the
immediate vicinity and wait until the
victim has fallen asleep how it is able
to determine the state of sleep is
unknown but it has shown to be accurate
in
time's out upon entering the mouth of
the new host as CP 439 will travel down
the trachea and take up residence in one
of the victims lungs in approximately
four to eight hours after awakening the
host will complain of chest pains and
shortness of breath followed shortly by
abdominal cramping the tightness in the
chest will increase as well as a fever
until the host is incapacitated it is
around this time that the onset of fibro
dysplasia ossificans progressiva FOP
occurs a disorder that is normally
genetic in nature that promotes growth
of bone into muscle tissue since the
production of new bone growth is so
rapid the procedure is also quite
painful for the subject with new bone
spurs occasionally protruding through
the flesh while this is happening the
host will become compelled to seek
shelter in a darkened enclosed space
such as inside household cabinetry
closets or heating duct work within the
first three days without treatment the
host will become completely withdrawn
and a mobile due to the extreme pain of
the new bone growth coupled with
difficulty breathing at this point the
subjects body will begin the final stage
of transformation into a bone hive
having concealed itself in its new home
the body of the host will huddle into a
fetal position entire portions of the
skeletal structure will shift along
until the host body is roughly spherical
in nature and reduced to three-quarters
of its original size new poem
protrusions will continue to grow and if
possible anchor the body permanently to
its new location the skeletal structure
is almost completely unrecognizable
having been converted to a round cage to
protect the internal organs and colony
at this point transformation is complete
the original queen that entered the host
will have produced 20 to 30 thousand
offspring that function as workers
drones and warriors in a typical insect
hive hierarchy since only the queen is
capable of reproduction the rest of the
hives inhabitants are fortunately
harmless safe for large strong abdominal
forceps of the Warriors the interior of
the original host is nearly
unrecognizable as a human body certain
organs are removed and used as food
while others are modified by the worker
insects to serve as egg incubation
chambers an ingenious method exists of
using the hosts own digestive system to
process pieces of organic materials
collected by the Warriors into a
nutritive slurry that feeds both the
colony and sustains the host hive
structure after four to six months a new
queen will emerge from within the ranks
and choose a drone to mate with at this
point the colony will destroy itself by
rupturing upon which the majority of the
insects died workers and drones are
unfit to survive outside the hosts hive
and Warriors will abandon the site
wandering away their tasks complete no
food will be consumed by the Warriors
that is nutritive slurry produced by the
hive of origin the new queen will
venture out fertilized to search for her
own new hive incredibly the trauma of
evacuation is not what finally causes
biological activity to cease in the hive
but starvation addendum in an experiment
doctor performed a range of tests to
determine the extent of damage to the
hosts body after it has finished
transformation into a hive while it had
been previously discovered in autopsy
that portions of the brain are hollowed
out to serve as food others are left
intact presumably to regulate what
bodily functions continue
during the last round of experimentation
took the opportunity to examine a hive
at close range shortly after the
transformation while the eyes are
eventually reached and used as a food
source at the point performed her
examination they were still intact
opening the eyelids and examining with a
flashlight something discovered that the
hosts eyes followed the beam
experimentation was terminated and no
further testing is scheduled okay I
think I speak for everyone here I don't
really want to know if that person is
alive so let's just say they're not and
end the lecture shall we yeah
okay so that's it thank you for
listening if indeed you still are and
you were all dismissed
good bye
I would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert GM's Sabah
Chris all Pablo ice 917 Caleb
Chaffins Karim el ash muy Justin de bra
Karima Thomas Morin Curie kuma white
crew and jayvo Jack crystal spice my
archive curator Nick King modding and
the wanderer thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you